quand et squillaci va pas et tout ça en
toi c'est trop gros ça va trop vite
surtout et c'est aux connards regarde
les sont tout le temps par si ça va nous
retomber dessus c'est mes amis c'est des
bons gars je te jure douce et tes amis
c'est des potes de poker tu les connais
que de la nuit ils en ont rien à [ __ ]
de ta gueule tout ce qui les intéresse
et flamber baiser l'écu s'en fout plein
pif va droit dans le mur avec eux je
sais au fond de toi tu le sais tout en
tentant d'y dolly on va refourguer cache
encore de trois mois on va faire
prospérer après les quito c'est du vent
et on y sera dur derrière nous puis sont
venus sur baiser serait déjà fait corps
allait passer avec tu vas d'offrir une
piste derrière les barreaux
à demain
mon père
cette entreprise une trentaine d'années
ça fait une dizaine d'années que je
dirige et fumo bas comme un forcené pour
la maintenir à flot pour moi quelqu'un
qui fait peur de rater
personne n'a prêté natta situation je
suis désolé mais il faut que tu dépose
le bilan
vos maris femmes incapables de nice et a
été consulté durant ma femme et office
sa femme est avant tout ma fille c'est
le cas raison tu es vraiment qu'un
minable
vous ferez les fours qui pour celui qui
avait tu pourrais me trouver une société
bidon et ouvrir un compte bancaire les
trois ans nous parle de pitié de la tva
sur du gaz carbonique
tu peux rembourser des dettes et même
garder ton entreprise pourquoi tu
voudrais partager avec nous on est de
fous plus on mr reprend antoine c est
internet quand tu fais ça tu assumes
mais il faut pour commencer les milieux
où est ce qu'on va trouver tout cet
hôtel une boîte qui amène un peu de la
boxe peut nous aider l'enfant on pousse
paume ou le plus sûr ce serait d'ouvrir
les comptes offshore pleurons créé notre
propre mois du tri
ça veut dire que si je te nomme 5
aujourd'hui tu m'as en disant trop c'est
trop gros that lovin ça va nous retomber
dessus
[Musique]
la dernière fois que je t'ai vu c'était
pour me dire que tu était criblé de
dettes prends moi après tu reviens avec
les poches pleines d'argent
une voiture qui vaut plus cher que ma
mère tu es un mec comme toi le premier
mannequin je rencontre dans ma vie des
erreurs de ma vie aurait été d'avoir
totalement sous-estimé ce petit caux
avec des prix plus de 100 briques tout
une pointe avec 10 plaqués tu crois qu
on est quittes
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que vous avez dans la
tronche bordel quoi vous n'êtes pas
assez dans la merde comme ça on rigole
plus
général d'empiré ne doit jamais et le
combat avec un seul plan le grand art ce
savoir changer pour nonna bataille
[Musique]